>> Greg: ANOTHER WAKE-UP CALL
TO THE TEACHER UNIONS WHO WENT
ALL IN ON PANDEMIC SCHOOL
CLOSURE.
TWO-THIRDS OF PARENTS BELIEVE
RETURNING TO SCHOOL GET THEIR
KIDS AN OPPORTUNITY TO REGAIN
NORMALCY.
BY ENGAGING IN SOCIAL
ACTIVITIES, THOSE ARE FUN.
61% BUT THEIR CHILD BEHIND BOTH
SOCIALLY AND DEVELOP MENTALLY,
THAT'S A LONG WORD PAIR THE
BIDEN WHITE HOUSE COULDN'T CARE
LESS.
THEY ARE TOO BUSY HOBNOBBING
WITH RANDI WEINGARTEN WHO POSTED
THIS PHOTO OF COURSE OF HERSELF
AT BIDEN'S INFLATION PARTY.
TALK ABOUT BAD OPTICS.
BIDENS UNMASKED TACTIC FILMIC
EDUCATION SECRETARY RECENTLY
VISITED SCHOOLS PACKED WITH
MASKED KIDS AND THEY INSIST THEY
WERE JUST FOLLOWING PROTOCOL.
DANA, I SUPPOSE A SURVEY LIKE
THIS WOULD BE A WAKE-UP CALL TO
TEACHERS UNIONS, BUT HOW CAN YOU
WAKE-UP A CORPSE?
WE'LL BE RIGHT BACK.
>> Dana: THAT'S A GOOD
QUESTION.
I'M GOING TO WORK ON THAT -- I
WAS NOT PREPARED FOR THAT ONE.
I THINK WHAT COULD BE A WAKE-UP
CALL IS THIS ELECTION.
YOU SAW IT IN NEW JERSEY AND
SEVERAL WOMEN RUNNING ON THE
REPUBLICAN SIDE OF THINGS NOT
JUST FOR CONGRESS BUT ALSO
SCHOOL BOARD AND A LOT OF THEM
ARE CALLING IT MOMENTS ON A
MISSION.
THEY REALIZE WHAT'S HAPPENING TO
THEIR CHILDREN.
WE AS A SOCIETY -- WE OWE THESE
CHILDREN A WAY TO GET BACK TO
GRADE LEVEL.
BECAUSE THE REST OF THEIR LIVES
THEY WILL BE HARMED BY THIS IF
WE DON'T ACTUALLY DO SOMETHING.
WHY DON'T THE PARENT START A
UNION?
IT IS A JOB.
WE JUST ASSUMED THAT TEACHERS
HAVE UNIONS, DISK WHY DON'T
PARENTS FORM A UNION?
I THINK YOU COULD RUN IT, JESSE.
THAT'S A GREAT IDEA, SOMEBODY
SHOULD RUN WITH THAT.
>> Jesse: SEEMS LIKE A LOT OF
WORK.
RAISING YOUR KIDS AND BEING IN
UNION AND HAVING A JOB.
I'M NOT INTO IT, GREG.
YOU VOLUNTEER.
>> Greg: I DON'T HAVE KIDS.
>> Jesse: THAT YOU KNOW OF.
HERE'S THE DEAL, EVERYBODY KNEW
THE CONSERVATIVES WERE RIGHT WE
WERE RIGHT ABOUT THE MASS, WE
WERE RIGHT ABOUT THE REMOTE
LEARNING.
WE HAVE PARENTAL INSTINCTS ABOUT
HOW YOUR CHILDREN ARE GOING TO
THRIVE.
THE DEMOCRATS HAD BOUGHT OUT AND
IF YOU RAISE YOUR VOICE WERE
GOING TO SPY ON YOU.
NOW RANDI WEINGARTEN ARE SHOWING
UP THERE, SHE IS PROBABLY A OF
JAMES TAYLOR.
SHE LIKES JAMES TAYLOR AND SHE
WAS REWARDED BY BIDEN FOR
GETTING OUT THE VOTE.
SHE'S A POLITICAL PLAYER.
THAT'S ALL THAT IS.
STEVE JOBS, DO YOU REMEMBER
THEM.
SAID SOMETHING -- HE SAID STUFF
THAT IF HE SAID TODAY HE BE A
SEXIST.
THE PARENTS BOTH OF THEM STOPPED
PAYING ATTENTION TO WHAT WAS
HAPPENING AT THEIR CHILDREN'S
SCHOOLS.
THAT'S WHEN THE SCHOOL STARTED
TO GO DOWNHILL.
BECAUSE THE CONSUMER, OR THE
CUSTOMER, THE PERSON PAYING THE
TAXES TO GET THE END FOR A
NATION HAD NO IDEA WHAT WAS
GOING ON BEHIND THE COUNTER.
THE TEACHERS AND THE
ADMINISTRATORS STARTED PUSHING
THIS CRAZY STUFF.
THE NEXT THING YOU KNOW THAT
PANDEMIC COMES IN YOUR LICKING
AND ZOOMING YOU LIKE THAT OUT OF
MY CHILD IS LEARNING?
THIS IS BETTER NOW -- SOUNDS
LIKE THE PARENTS COULD USE THE
UNION.
YOU JUST BASICALLY ARGUED FOR A
RIGHT TO WORK.
WHAT'S TO BE DONE NOW?
IT SEEMS LIKE IT SO POLITICIZED
THAT EVEN EDUCATION IS HOPELESS.
>> Geraldo: ONE THING WE HAVE
TO DO IS NOT TO LOCK DOWN THESE
CALLS EVER AGAIN REALLY IS A
PLAGUE AND WE KNOW ABOUT IT.
I MEAN WE DIDN'T KNOW AND
SCIENCE WE WERE BOGGLING OUR WAY
THROUGH THE RESULTS WERE
CATASTROPHIC FOR THE CHILDREN
OBVIOUSLY.
I THINK PEOPLE MAKE A MISTAKE.
THEY DON'T DIFFERENTIATE BETWEEN
THE TEACHERS AND THE TEACHERS
UNIONS.
IT'S A VERY DIFFERENT -- WHEN
YOU LOOK AT RANDI WEINGARTEN
IT'S EASY TO SAY REMEMBER WHY WE
IDEALIZE TEACHERS.
THEY WORK FOR LESS, THEY PUT
KIDS FIRST, THEY SACRIFICE HER,
THEY BUY THEIR ERASERS OUT OF
THEIR OWN MEAGER FUNDS AND SO
FORTH.
THE TEACHERS UNION CAN BE
RUTHLESS.
NOBODY CAN SUGGEST FOR A MINUTE
THAT THE STAY OUT IN CHICAGO FOR
INSTANCE WAS MOTIVATED BY
SCIENCE.
I MEAN THEY WENT -- REMEMBER
THEY WANTED TO PUT IN THE NEW
VENTILATING SYSTEM.
THEY PUT IN A NEW VENTILATING
SYSTEM AND THEY HAD TO DO
OTHER -- IT BECAME RIDICULOUS.
TEACHERS UNION IS JUST LIKE THE
TEAMSTERS AND EVERY OTHER UNION,
THEY ARE THERE TO GET THE TRAINS
NOW THE STRIKE JUST AVERTED
TODAY -- THERE OUT THERE FOR $24
RACES PER HOUR, LISTEN, I LIKE
UNIONS.
I LOVE UNIONS.
UNIONS ARE GREAT FOR WORKERS.
UNIONS RAISE THE LEVEL OF THE
STANDARD OF LIVING.
BUT REMEMBER WHAT IT IS.
RANDI WEINGARTEN IS NOT COME OF
MRS. FLOOR FLORAS THAT BRINGS
YOU THE COOKIES.
SHE'S A LABOR BOSS.
>> Greg: HE'S GOT A POINT,
JUDGE, THAT THE TEACHERS
UNION -- IT'S CALLED THE
TEACHERS UNION FOR A UNION PIT
IS ABOUT THE TEACHERS, IT'S NOT
ABOUT THE KIDS.
>> Jeanine: IT'S NEVER BEEN
THE SAD PART IS NOW
"THE WALL STREET JOURNAL" SAYS
THAT I THINK FOR THE LONGEST
TIME WITHOUT THAT 87% OF THE
MONEY WAS NOT SPENT OF THE
HUNDRED AND $90 BILLION WE GAVE
THE SCHOOLS.
"THE WALL STREET JOURNAL" NOW
SAYS THAT 93% OF THE MONEY HAS
NOT BEEN SPENT.
SO THE QUESTION IS FOR ME IF
COVID IS OVER, WE SHOULD BE ABLE
TO CRAWL BACK THAT $190 BILLION.
I WANT THAT MONEY BACK.
CLAW IT BACK.
THE WHOLE IDEA WAS TO MAKE
SCHOOLS SAFER THE KIDS ON THE
TEACHERS.
WILL IT SAVE RIGHT NOW.
IF YOU CAN'T FIGURE OUT AIR
CONDITIONING VENTS SO THAT ALL
OF THESE SCHOOLS IN DENVER,
PHILLY, BALTIMORE, SAN DIEGO, AS
WELL AS A FEW OTHERS -- THEY
CAN'T EVEN GET THROUGH
SEPTEMBER.
GET THE MONEY BACK.
THEY DAMAGED OUR KIDS, THEY
DON'T GIVE A DAMN ABOUT WHAT
HAPPENS TO OUR KIDS, THEY ONLY
CARE ABOUT THEMSELVES AS
EVIDENCED BY THE FACT THAT
EDUCATION SECRETARY WAS SPEAKING
TO KIDS, HE HAD DID NOT HAVE A
RIGHT MASK ON WHICH WAS A REPLAY
OF STACEY ABRAMS IN GEORGIA WITH
NO MASK.
ANOTHER DEMOCRAT TALKING TO KIDS
WHO WERE ALL MASKED UP.
THIS IS ALL A HEAD TRIP FOR
THEM.
IT'S ALL ABOUT THE MONEY.
IT'S TIME WE GOT THE MONEY BACK.
THEY DIDN'T NEED IT, GET A BACK.
>> Gre